- We will proceed as
we did in the morning,
in alphabetical order.
So I'll just introduce
each of the panelists now
and then get going.
Our first speaker will be John Bender
who is Professor of English
and Comparative Literature at Stanford
and former Director of the
Stanford Humanities Center.
And author, most recently
of "The Culture of Diagram"
with Michael Marrinan,
and "Ends of Enlightenment."
And then we will hear from Sophie Gee
who is Associate Professor
of English at Princeton.
She's the author of "Making Waste"
and "The Scandal of the Season,"
and is currently finishing a book entitled
"Infidelity: The Rise of
the Sacrificial Novel."
We will then hear from Sarah Tindal Kareem
who is Associate Professor
of English at UCLA.
Her current research
focuses on how the metaphors
18th-century writers used to
talk about reading fiction,
in particular the metaphors
of entering into a fictional world
or following a narrative thread.
Reflect and afford distinct
modes of readerly attachment.
Wendy Lee is Assistant Professor
in the English Department at NYU
where she teaches 18th-century
Literature and Philosophy.
She is finishing a book that she says
with appropriate laconic quality
about the origins of the Bartleby problem.
And finally last but not
least, Courtney Weiss Smith
is Associate Professor
of English at Wesleyan.
And her recent book, "Empiricist Devotions:
"Science, Religion and Poetry
in Early 18th-century England"
won the Cowen Prize.
- Yay.
- So yay.
With no further ado, John.
- I had a title and I'll explain
it to you as we go along.
It's "Foley Effects in the Gothic:
"Sound in 'The Castle of Otranto.'"
And this handout's
going around, I'll wait.
Don't start my ten minutes yet Ruth.
(everyone laughs)
So a few modern critics have written
specifically about sound in
the Gothic novel, but very few.
But noises were considered
strong generic markers
of the Gothic in the 18th century itself.
Three different periodicals of the time.
And I owe these references
to Tasha Eccles, who's here.
Offer profiles of the
Gothic, and they insist
as say did, the spirit of
the public journals in 1798.
That the Gothic required, and I quote,
"Noises, whispers and groans
"and indeed demanded three
score at least, of each."
And other profiles add things
like whistles, wind, rushes, howls, rain,
creaking doors and clanking chains.
So the early inclusion of
sound as a marker of the Gothic
works to confirm my intuition
that sounds are less
prominent in what we can call
standard English novels of
the period than in the Gothic.
And indeed for the 19th century,
the Lit labs at Stanford
has had a project which seems to show
that across the 19th century,
novels become less loud and noisy
with a decline of words
like shriek, cried, screamed
and other such things.
Conversely, when I opened
"Otranto" to prepare this talk
I was overwhelmed by the
profusion of sonic dimensions
in the text's beginnings and thereafter.
The eruptions of sound everywhere
and also marked silences.
Now this encounter brings
me to Foley effects.
One very prominent kind
of sound effect in film.
So what are Foley effects?
Like virtually every sound
in a film you attend,
other than dialogue, they're
laid down on a soundtrack
after the shooting of the film.
Only dialogue is recorded generally.
They're superimposed by the invisible hand
of the Foley artist.
I'm viewing Walpole here
as an unseen sound artist
who calls attention to crucial noises.
And Walpole sounds, like those in films
are highly selective and
very, very importantly
louder than in real life.
That those glasses
clinking, the lock latching,
the footsteps creaking,
they're always louder.
There are exceptions and I'll
mention those in a minute.
So he simulates a sense
of real sonic experience
using the unreal device of printed words.
Michel Chion says of film,
great sound theorist.
He says the realest art of cinema
has progressed only by straining
against its own principle
through forceful doses of un-realism.
And I would say that
"Otranto" fits this as well.
The point being that what we
perceive as realism in film
is actually very stylized indeed.
It's a series of simulations.
Now Foley sounds are
made with real objects
but disconnected from the real.
They're simulations.
Foley effects and other sounds effects
they achieve realism, but often
by employing the not real.
A famous instance in the literature
on sound and film, is snow.
Real snow does not sound like snow.
You have to use cornstarch.
And real silk stockings don't
sound like silk stockings,
you have to use Nylon.
And there are countless other examples.
I'll mention some of them along the way.
The great sound engineer Walter
Murch made this observation
and it's been picked up
widely in the film criticism.
So this kind of realism, like I would say
realism in a novel in general,
does not equal the real.
So Foley effects almost always
imply the spectral therefore
because they come out of nowhere.
Chion, again has this term,
the audio visual contract.
And I think that's very
much at work in "Otranto."
The idea is that when we see a film.
If we just saw the image, or
we just heard the soundtrack
it would be ineffective.
There's a audio visual contract
in which we witness them together
and they have this magical, realistic,
generally realistic character.
So there's a synergistic
co-presence of image and sound.
So what are the traits of Foley effects?
They're actual sounds on soundtracks
like locks, boards, floorboards,
clinking glasses, folding sheet metal.
So sometimes they're actual sounds
of things that may appear in the film.
They're almost always louder
than they would be in real life.
Now silence in real life
never is truly silent.
You hear that in the background here.
So if you were making a film of this room.
Your Foley artist would record that sound
and lay it on the track
as the sound of this room.
Foley puts all of those
kinds of sounds on film.
Street noise, the noises of a hotel,
doors closing, people
talking, TVs on and so forth.
But still, the differentiation between
silence and sound effects
is very important in film.
And a very famous example
is this extremely short
total silence in "Godfather II" at the end
when Michael is sitting by the lake
having had his brother murdered.
And the sound slowly goes
down to absolute silence.
Novels can give us absolute
silence and "Otranto" does that.
And this may be the moment to mention
Robert Barsund's assertion that
with sound coming into film
silence in film became possible.
Now silent films weren't really silent.
I mean there was orchestras
and all sorts of things.
But, you can't have one without the other.
You can't have sound effects,
silence without sound effects.
Now, sound effects in film in general
are aimed at the audience.
But there are exceptions in sound effects
that render psycho effects of a character.
Very common in horror
films and we see that.
I'll show you in a minute in "Otranto"
with Isabella down in the
subterranean corridor.
So having told you something about Foley
I'm gonna show you the making of Foley
for a short film sequence, police chase.
On your left will be the film
and on the right will
be the Foley artists.
And notice that sometimes
they're doing what's happening
and sometimes they're doing
something completely different.
This is gonna be two minutes.
You're on Michelle.
- Foley is the process
of creating sound effects
live in a studio along with
prerecorded piece of video.
Foley artists use a variety of props
to create or replace sounds
that cannot properly be captured on set.
Here, you see two Hollywood Foley artists
bringing an action sequence to life.
(audience laughs)
(sound of clattering items)
(sound of glass smashing)
(audience laughs)
(sound of items banging)
(sound of items falling)
(audience laughs)
(sound of a pipe falling)
- I think we can stop there.
You're missing the part where the cop,
where the thief punches the cop.
And this is an example of
a different sound creating the real
because what the Foley artists
punch, is a leg of lamb.
(everyone laughs)
Real punches don't make
much sound apparently
and so you have to punch
something else to make the sound.
So what we have here,
sometimes is they're doing
what the character in the films are doing,
other times they're making
some kind of artful substitute.
And so they're producing a
realism by a high artificiality
that substitutes alternatives very often
for normal sounds that we would hear.
Now let's look quickly at the handout.
I'll just point out a
couple of things here.
There are more highlighted
things than I can cover.
I believe.
But the first is the
famous rustling sound.
The proportionable quantity
of plumes on the fatal helmet.
This seems to me a perfect example
of the audio visual contract.
You have the plumes moving.
Okay, without the rustling
sound, without that Foley effect
it would not be the
vivid thing that it is.
And then the pictures sighing.
In some Gothic novels, pictures sigh
and then step out of the frame,
which would be even better.
And then once here, the second part,
the lower part of the castle.
I'm sure you're all
familiar with this flight
of Isabella into the lower
chambers of the castle.
And there's an awful silence there.
Now that's a total novelistic silence.
That's not the silence of
this room or a Foley silence.
The novel can give that to us.
But then blasts of wind shake the doors
as she passed, rusty hinges creak.
They're re-echoed down the labyrinth.
So you can imagine how these Foley artists
would create that echo.
But then something happens.
Every murmur struck her with new terror
and the sounds move inside
into phantasms and
imaginations of her head.
On a film, those would still be rendered.
But we would intuit through
the audio visual contract
that we were now fusing
the sounds with her mind
rather than with some external
object like a door hinge.
Then we get the gust of wind,
the lamp, total darkness.
If you, I think turn over.
This is where Theodore appears.
And the moonshine that
Jonathan mentioned earlier
coming down and striking the trap door
that they're looking for.
She touches it, the spring clicks.
Goes down in total darkness.
Now total darkness is
also very hard to achieve
in the real world, but you
can have it in the novel.
It's very hard to achieve on film actually
because then the image goes away
and we just have a blank screen.
So then she goes down
through the trap door.
And I'll just close the discussion
of the handout with this.
"Shut the trap door after you," she says.
"He let the door slip out of his hands.
"It fell and the spring closed over it."
The noise, and now becomes diegetic again.
The noise of the falling door
had been heard by Manfred.
So now we take off and Manfred cries out.
Okay, so this is basically my intuition
that there's a kind of
special sound in "Otranto"
that produces realism through the unreal.
And I just note a few other
places in a Gothic novel
where I think we could discuss
this, if we weren't doing the
conference equivalent of speed dating.
Various sequences in "Udolpho" where
Valancourt is playing the lute.
Tasha gave me that one.
The odd lack of sound
at the end of "The Monk."
When I was working on this, I thought
oh, the end of "The Monk" will
be very noisy, but it's not.
Very interesting.
Thrown voices in
"Wieland" and "Confessions
of a Justified Sinner."
Rochester's mysterious
cry to Jane in "Jane Eyre."
The wind in "Wuthering Heights."
And lots and lots of
sounds in Edgar Allan Poe.
So it's just a kind of informal
intuition about the novel.
I had a lot of fun reading
these great film theorists.
I have one of Michel Chion's books here.
And Walter Murch is only on the web
but he's absolutely fantastic.
He did the sound for the "Godfather" films
and many other truly memorable films.
So that's it.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- John you've got me thinking about
a lot of different things but including
what would be the speed dating
version of a conference.
Maybe marriage, I don't know.
(audience laughs)
- Maybe divorce, you all leave.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay so I want to talk with my ten minutes
about authority, about inwardness
and about how the two states coexist.
With some passing references
to "The Castle of Otranto."
And I'm gonna present this as a list
with some detailed points.
And I'm into lists at the moment
because they don't require an argument.
So you can do what you like with them.
Okay, so point one.
So this is a very odd book
which relapses from time to time
into other kinds of oddity.
The sort of, quote
unquote "realistic spaces"
that we would associate
with 18th-century places
like the nursery, the boarding
school, the men's club.
I think that these sites
are sort of kicking around unacknowledged
in "The Castle of Otranto."
In these moments where the
dialogue really could go
in either direction.
It could belong in a realist novel
or well it should belong
in a realist novel
but instead it's in a Gothic novel.
And I've chosen those sites advisably.
So I'll tell you why in a minute.
What we see in "Otranto" is that
no space is beyond the reach of authority.
And the fact that there's
this constant crossover
between the Gothic and the real in "Otranto"
invites us to notice how
both modes involve acts
of what I'm calling
overreaching authority.
So where some kind of coercion
involves a kind of
infiltration into minds,
into bedrooms, into bodies.
These things take place
in novels of all kinds.
Despite the ways in which novels
stake out a very strong spacial discipline
or boundary creation for themselves.
We've talked about doors and things
but just the big spaces of novels.
Country houses, the picaresque mode,
the castle, the grotto, the vault.
These are all places
where we might think that
authority might be able to be contained
rather than continue to overreach.
But novels are places
where everything can reach
into everything else.
Often ludicrously.
And really the only place
I can think of in "Otranto"
where overreaching or
reaching is not as successful,
is not achieved, is when Theodore
can't reopen the trap door
and reach into the
tunnel or whatever it is.
So that's point one.
Point two is that there is a
group of contemporary thinkers
like people now, who are
interested in revisiting the status
of faith and belief as a post-Christian
or new humanist form of understanding.
These people are trying to
think about the validity
of convictions of a
certain type of conviction
that is obligatory, involuntary
and which is oriented toward
idealization and abstraction
rather than toward
empiricism or materiality.
So the key terms here are a
type of understanding that is
conferred upon the
individual as an obligation
and which reaches toward an
idealization or an abstraction.
Takes us out of the empirical.
So these thinkers are arguing for
renewed attention actually
to a form of overreaching.
The reaching of obligation into places
that have scrupulously been freed
from the politics of obligation,
like minds and feelings.
This is supposed to be what
happens in the 18th century.
Turns out it doesn't work.
People are revisiting this.
The question that's
prevailing in a certain strain
of modern contemporary philosophy
is whether it's possible
to perform an action
or hold a position without
choice, but still be free.
So in other words, there is a return to
pre-secular ideas about
belief and behavior.
About the idea that beliefs and behaviors
can be made obligatory.
Which in the early modern
period would have been
constructed by inflexible,
among other things
by inflexible religious
forms, forms of belief.
And this type of obligation
has been called obedience.
And obedience is pretty out of fashion.
So the theoretical move among this group
of post-Christian new humanist scholars
is to re-constitute obedience,
but to lose the belief
and behavior part of it.
So to think of a form of obligation
that might be freeing
because it doesn't produce
prescriptions around belief or action.
So it's quite subtle, really.
So the religious anthropologist Talal Asad
has summarized what I've just said as
the notion that formality is necessarily
an external form of
coercion is questionable.
In other words, he's asking
whether it's possible
to enter a system of
meaning without choice
and yet not be unacceptably
constrained by it.
Okay, so my third point.
Which as advertised, is not
precisely related to one or two.
Is that we think of the 18th century
as the moment in which critique emerges
as a way of thinking.
So quick revision of what critique is.
It's an attempt to problematize
or trouble obligation.
Specifically the kind of obligation
that is involved in
the production of facts
and other fixed or immovable truths.
So facts command acquiescence.
Not only to what they inform us of
but of how they do the informing.
We have to submit to that.
And critique re-installs a care
for personal interiority and inwardness
in an effort to override the
rise of the modern state.
I get that that's a super duper summary
but let's just go with it for now.
Critique sort of has a preference for
what in a different political moment
we might call the soft truth.
And what I mean by that
is knowledge that must be
produced counterintuitively
that depends upon logic,
that infiltrates the box
or the trap door of a fact
and reveals it to be a kind of fiction.
And you know, a few years ago
Bruno Latour got very worried about that
and gave a critique of
critique in which he said that
it was time to, or maybe it was time to
restore real facts and to
defend them against the charge
that they are
fake facts or liberal conspiracies.
In other words, that the left was now
being obligated to do
what it had previously
had to move so decisively away from.
Namely to restore the fact as a
primary epistemological unit.
Okay.
So that's three.
Point four.
The Walpole that I work
with is the wrong Walpole.
I work with the unfashionable one, Robert.
Who obviously was Horace's father.
And it's interesting to me
that Horace is the third son.
That seems relevant somehow.
Anyway, Walpole, Robert
Walpole's administration.
Again, this is a massive summary.
But it really was invested in facts
and it was invested in the
fictional machinery of statehood
that was required to generate facts.
Walpole and the Whigs of the
earlier 18th century were
their commitment to liberty
produced a model of statehood
in which participation
became entirely involuntary.
So one of the chief spokespeople
for Robert Walpole's model of statehood.
A kind of hygienic, very
efficient secular state
that was separate from the
church but had a national church
was a guy called Benjamin Hoadly.
Who some people might have heard
of, some people won't have.
He delivered a very contentious sermon
at a particular moment during Walpole's
actually it was before
Walpole became Prime Minister
it was in 1717, but he continued
on into Walpole's period
and became his sort of propagandist.
Anyway, Hoadly said that
an act of Parliament
should not reach to
the inward disposition.
And he used this claim as
the basis for designing
a kind of contemporary theology
that pushed belief, pushed religion,
pushed abstraction and idealization
to the margins of the social world
and in-stated what we think
of as the modern state.
And what I want to do,
really quickly is read
a passage from the sermon that Hoadly gave
in which he laid this out.
And what I want you to
notice about the passage
is its Gothic elaboration.
It's extremely overwrought.
It relies on a kind of
theological hysteria.
Though without sound effects.
And what I want us to think about here
is this idea that the production of
an un-Gothic state, of a
state of material realities
uncontaminated by their overreaching
into other closed systems.
That the production of that also produces
a kind of Gothic register.
So here's the passage.
"If any men upon Earth
"have a right to add to
the sanction of His laws
"that is to increase the number
"or alter the nature of
the rewards and punishments
"of His subjects in matters
of conscience or salvation,
"they are so far kings in His stead
"and reign in their own kingdom"
Him here being Christ "and not in His.
"Though it is whenever
they erect tribunals
"and exercise the judgment
over the consciences of men
"and assume themselves
to the determination
"of such points as cannot be determined
"but by one who knows the hearts
"or when they make any of their own
"declarations or decisions
"to concern and affect the
state of Christ's subjects
"with regard to the favor of God.
"This is so far the
taking of Christ's kingdom
"out of his hands and
placing it into their own."
So I'm going to end by reflecting
that it took an enormous amount
rhetorically speaking, cognitively
and in terms of.
Well, it took a lot, it took a lot
to segregate conscience and action.
To separate the world of the fact
from the world of the
idealization or abstraction.
And a lot of that work was done
during Walpole's period in office.
And that I think that "Otranto" is
considering some of the implications of
that segregation. Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Alright I'm really happy to be here.
I wanted to thank Jonathan and Nicole
and everyone else for being here.
I really enjoyed hearing all the panelists
and seeing lots of connections between
the observations we've been making.
What I'm gonna be talking about today
relates in a roundabout kind of way
to the book project I'm
working on at the moment.
And I wanted to begin by
situating a little bit
and explaining that
this second book project
in its current iteration
emerged from a crisis I had
about two or three months ago
where I was just sort of
pathologically procrastinating
and found that I did not
want to write the book
that I had designed for myself to write.
Which was, it was titled "Suspended World"
and it was meant to be about
these kinds of metaphors
or delicate enclosures, like bubbles
and other types of spaces
and thinking about how those worked
as metaphors for fiction in the period.
But I'd become really just fascinated by
Hogarth's account of intricacy
in "The Analysis of Beauty."
And I kept telling everybody
I just want to write about intricacy.
I just want to shelve that whole thing.
And then this is a very, very
kind of LA epiphany story.
I was driving along Sunset Boulevard.
And if you've ever driven along Sunset
it's an extremely winding road
full of these sort of hairpin bends.
And I suddenly decided that
no, this was a book about
two different figures.
And so I re-titled it.
I actually pulled off
Sunset to write this down.
And I decided it was gonna be called
"The Thread and the Shell:
Forms of Attachment
"in 18th-century Literature."
And that it was gonna be about these two
paradigms or gestalts, for
the way in which people,
readers in the 18th century
are being invited to read.
One of which is a model of
pursuit and following a thread
and the other one is of entering
a kind of delicate enclosure,
and that's the shell.
So in the course of bringing
these two ideas together
I've become really
fascinated with Daedalus.
For reasons partly to do with
the nature of his inventions
and his interest in
both threads and shells.
So if this paper had a title
it would be called Daedalian "Otranto."
Except that I don't really know
how to pronounce the word, Daedalian.
Daedalian, so I won't call it that
but that's what it would
be if it had a title.
Okay.
So the adjective Daedalian,
which I only discovered maybe a month ago
means of or in the style of Daedalus.
Skillful, ingenious formed with art
resembling the Labyrinth of Daedalus
that he designed at Crete
that housed the Minotaur.
Intricate and maze-like.
So specifically my interests in this
are kind of synonyms for intricate.
But it's also, and this picks up on
what Sophie was talking about.
It's a term that Bruno Latour
uses and turns into a noun.
So for Latour, a Daedalian
is a technical mediation
that creates detours.
And I think this actually also
kind of connects to what
you were saying about
the question of whether
something can be constraining
but you can also be free at the same time.
So a Daedalian constrained behavior
but not in a way that's deterministic.
But that rather sort of pushes
you in certain directions.
And his main example,
this is in "Pandora's Hope."
His main example of a
Daedalian is a speed bump.
But in that same chapter
where he discusses
the Daedalian, the speed
bumps the Daedalian.
He also says that fiction is a Daedalian.
Fictions are also detours that we can make
as he says, without leaving our seats.
So with this concept in mind
I decided that Walpole strikes
me as a Daedalian writer.
Someone who, like Daedalus himself,
most famously in his labyrinth
shapes matter in a way
that creates detours.
Walpole's letters, and I'm gonna be citing
bits of text that have already
come up, fascinatingly today.
Walpole's letters refer to
both reading and writing
as a matter of imaginatively
moving bodies in space.
Moving or stilling, I
should say, bodies in space.
So when he's contemplating
adding a bower to Strawberry Hill.
He wonders if he, and this is a quotation.
"Must go and read Spenser and
wade through his allegories
"and drawling stanzas
to get at a picture." End quote.
And we kind of have this
sense in that moment
that he really wants a snapshot.
He wants a picture of romance, of a bower.
He doesn't want a peregrination
or to have to pursue something.
But Spenser demands pursuit
and that kind of reading as a detour.
Then on other occasions,
the activity of spooling out narrative
just lurches to a stop very suddenly.
When he's writing "Otranto," he recalls.
And this is the part of the passage
that Cindy quoted earlier.
"I was so engrossed with my tale
"that one evening I wrote from
the time I had drunk my tea,
"about six o'clock
"til half an hour after one in the morning
"when my hand and fingers were so weary
"that I could not hold the
pen to finish the sentence
"but left Matilda and Isabella talking
"in the middle of a paragraph."
So there I think
or we have both of those
situations in mind.
The wading through Spenser
to get at a picture
and the kind of writing in a kind of rush
and then leaving Matilda and Isabella
marooned mid paragraph.
I think Walpole shapes space in such a way
as to produce these kinds of situations.
in "Otranto," in the novel itself
he shapes space in such a way,
that enclosures turn into passages
and passages turn into enclosures.
In which tableaus move and moving
bodies stop in their tracks.
And I think, in staging these shifts
between stillness and motion
he's reflecting on the relationship
between two modes of representation.
And this is where I'm getting
to the kind of thread and shell idea.
That in which a frame encloses content
and that in which content
unfolds progressively
in a way that needs to
be pursued or followed.
So the famous moment in which
the portrait of Manfred's
grandfather quits its panel
is only the most striking
of several instances
in which a frame becomes a threshold.
And this is itself as
I've discovered recently
through reading and lastly about Daedalus,
a kind of Daedalian spectacle.
So Daedalian, I should just decide
how I'm gonna pronounce that word.
Daedalian sculpture is sculpture that is
supposedly so lifelike
that Daedalus was said
to produce statues that
walked, or that moved.
And Aristophanes has a lost play
that supposedly turns
on a statue of Daedalus'
that just walks and moves.
The moment in which the
portrait quits its panel
foreshadows one that
follows in quick succession.
Another one that's been
alluded to several times today
in which Theodore's supposed to be
confined under the fatal helmet,
escapes from the helmet
into the vault below.
When Manfred finds him, he discovers.
And this is another quotation that
"one of the cheeks of the enchanted cask
"had forced its way through
the pavement of the court
"as his servants had let
it fall over the peasant.
"And had broken through into
the vault, leaving a gap
"through which the peasant
had pressed himself."
And I'm gonna come back a little bit
to that language just in a minute.
But just to say, in "Otranto"
every time providence
opens a gap in the roof
it also slams shut a trap door.
(audience laughs)
Isabel urges Theodore to shut
the trap door after he exits.
But as we've just heard, it slams shut
before he has the chance,
thereby as John was saying
signaling his presence to Manfred.
"'What noise was that,' said Manfred
"'Which I heard as I entered the cloister?'
"'A door clapped,' said the peasant.
"'I heard it as well as you.'"
Moments like these turn
passages into enclosures
and enclosures into passages.
In ways, and I guess this
is my gambit or claim here.
That seem to assert the
agency of the frame itself.
It is the helmet, not Theodore
that forces its way through the floor
in that passage I read before,
with the cheeks breaking
down into the floor below.
It's the door that claps,
not Theodore who shuts it.
And I wonder if we might see these moments
and this is speculative.
As ones in which the border
exerts its own agency
as textual incarnations of the arabesque.
That movement in which
decorative and ornamental forms
associated with borders and frames.
That movement associated
with those kinds of frames
and also often comprising
of leaf work and shell work.
So then my final, this is my final point.
But I'm gonna try to
extemporise a little bit
in explaining what I mean.
I think that "Otranto's"
merging of frame and unframed
passage and enclosure
draws our attention then
to these two different
metaphors I want to suggest.
By which we understand representations.
On the one hand, it's a pursuit.
Manfred, and this is another quotation.
Is "Impatient to unravel this clue."
And again this is something
I didn't know until recently.
But that probably many of you know
that the word clue comes from
the ball of thread that you
use to navigate a labyrinth.
And so Walpole is using
that quite literally there.
The idea of unraveling a clue.
But at the same time,
and I think Gena was talking about this.
He's also transfixed by the helmet
and that's like another
model of kind of suspense
and being transfixed.
And you know, I think likewise in the way
"Otranto" works as a novel.
It's clearly, and Walpole
alludes to this in his preface.
It's trying to kind of
produce this kind of suspense
and tension in the reader
that we might associate more
with this pursuit model.
But it's also, and I
think it was again Cindy
who reminded me of this.
He characterizes the way
he comes up with a novel
as deriving from, or he says that
his head is filled with Gothic story.
That it's like, the we're
kind of traveling into that
space of the head filled with Gothic story
in a way that sort of suggests more of a
sort of static image that we
can enter a living picture.
So I think then,
I think that there's way in which
the novel is drawing our attention
to what we might call kind
of shellwork on the one hand
and threadwork in the other.
In ways in which these are two paradigms.
But in a way that's really
I don't know exactly how to describe it.
But just like vexing.
And I'll just end by saying
that the word unravel is,
I've become completely
obsessed with the word unravel.
An unraveled mystery is both
a solved mystery and an unsolved one
because the word unravel means
both the opposite of the verb ravel
and the opposite, and unravel.
I'm gonna get it wrong.
It just makes my head hurt
so much to think about it.
But in essence, it's a solved mystery
and an unsolved mystery.
And I think that what
Walpole is doing here
is something like sort of confronting us
with the limits of these different
hermeneutic modes or
modes of interpretation
and kind of just letting
us butt up against them.
And making our brain hurt by
having them constantly shift.
Shift modes and shift into another
just, all the time and constantly.
So I will leave it there.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- Okay.
Thank you, thank you Jonathan.
Thank you Nicole and Yale.
And I feel like the standard here for me
is the substitute teacher
because I'm a fill-in for Michael Gamer.
Okay, so just bear that in mind.
So I don't write about Walpole or "Otranto."
And I'll just do the best I can.
And I was saying to Gena.
I feel like this is the
gay version of her talk.
So keep that in mind.
Okay, so.
Re-reading "The Castle of Otranto"
I felt like most text,
this is one that is probably
best experienced as drag show.
And I mean like, all
queens kind of drag show.
And I'm talking about something that
I guess for Walpolians is so obvious
that you maybe didn't want
to talk about it today,
which is camp.
That sort of special
Walpolian sensibility.
And I thought for this
group, including Sarah
but I think also Sean
and Jessie and others.
We could apply camp as a test
for the experience of wonder.
And so my question would be
whether camp and campy pleasure
is antithetical to wonder.
Whether camp is too knowing,
too surface, too made.
Now, I think Sarah has already
provided an answer to this in her book
which is to say, no it's
not antithetical in novels.
She makes this gorgeous distinction
to wonder at and to
wonder about an object.
So in novel reading, you
have this double experience
of recognition and estrangement,
enchantment and disenchantment,
suspense and admiration.
What she beautifully calls,
the verisimilar marvelous.
So here's an example of that, I think.
In "The Castle of Otranto,"
read by Joseph Roach.
Take it away Joe.
Oh, okay in this scene also, sorry.
- Not here.
- Okay, let me queue you up.
So of course, Theodore, his shirt
he's about to be beheaded
or whatever by Manfred
and it's kind of like in a tennis match
when Rafael Nadal is playing
and after the match he
changes his sweaty shirt
and the whole audience
gasps at his abdominals.
So it's that kind of moment.
His shirt falls and reveals the shoulder,
and reveals the bloody arrow.
Take it away Professor Roach.
- "'Gracious heaven!'
(audience laughs)
"cried the holy man starting.
"'What do I see!
"'Is it my child, my Theodore!'
"The passions that
ensued must be conceived;
"They cannot be painted.
"The tears of the assistants
were suspended by wonder
"rather than stopped by joy.
"They seemed to inquire
in the eyes of their lord
"what they ought to feel.
"Surprise, doubt, tenderness, respect
"succeeded each other in
the countenance of the youth.
"He received, with modest submission,
"the effusion of the old man's tears,
"and embraces of giving a loose to hope
"and suspecting from what had passed,
"the inflexibility of Manfred's temper,
"he cast a glance towards
the prince as if to say,
"Canst thou be unmoved
at such a scene as this?"
(audience laughs)
(audience clapping)
- Okay, so you see the
two experiences there.
First that suspension of wonder.
So itself is a kind of
suspension of feeling
and then the servants have to say.
Okay, what am I supposed to feel here?
Am I supposed to feel?
They're looking to see where to,
what to slot into that emptiness.
And then that great moment
where Theodore is like.
Are you taking this in, are
you seeing how moving this is?
Okay, so to go back to camp.
So in the Sontag essay, there
are a few definitions of camp.
Camp is a logic of taste.
It's a way of looking.
It's self-parody plus self-love.
It's a tender feeling.
And here's Joseph Roach
last year, or a year before
at ASECS on Horace Walpole on camp.
So in Roach's statement.
"If kitsch, in Milan Kundera's formulation
"is the complete absence of shit.
"Think Cinderella's
Castle at Magic Mountain.
"Then camp by contrast means
kitsch with all the shit
"self-consciously and artfully restored."
Okay.
So number 56 in Sontag's essay.
"Camp taste is a kind of
love, love for human nature."
In other words, it doesn't judge.
So is "The Castle of Otranto," is the novel
a vehicle to accommodate
and exonerate male feeling?
Especially as, and Joe's
reading fleshes this out.
Especially primary
ambivalence towards women.
In other words, the Harvey
Weinstein story every time.
That is to say, men's
constitutional incapacity
to regulate their passions and
women's collective endurance
of their inevitable victimization.
Roach writes that camp isn't
about escape, but relief.
That it isn't transgression,
but expansion.
And here are some great formulations
that camp is an earnest insincerity.
That it's an exclamation point
disguised by a question mark.
"Camp reveals no hidden depth" he writes.
"Because what is hiding in plain sight
"needs all the therapeutic
recuperation it can get."
So re-reading it now in this moment.
I thought well what camp knows is that
the story of heterosexuality
is a really sad one.
And as Sandra McPherson, in person
and in her scrupulous
scholarship reminds me.
It's a story in which men are confused
and women get hurt or
destroyed all the time.
Camp allows us to see that
story for everything it's worth.
You get to feel sorry for it,
the whole catastrophe
we're tending towards
in Walpole's language.
You get to feel sorry for
it, feel sorry for ourselves,
our loved ones and our enemies.
But also like we get it.
Here is Roach again.
"Camp stages what is too
important to be taken seriously."
And I would adjust too what is too true
to be taken seriously.
Here's where I think that camp may be
incompatible with wonder.
And I rely here on Spinoza's
description of wonder.
Which is, when you behold an object
that for you has no precedence
in quality or degree.
And so it absorbs all of your attention
because you have no chain of
associations that it launches.
No field of reference in
beholding that object.
And this is Spinoza.
"Wonder is the conception of anything
"wherein the mind comes to a stand
"because the particular
concept in question
"has no connection with other concepts."
In "Otranto" and in camp, we see
the aggressively unavoidable
precedence of the story.
Its dogged, tragic and
hilarious persistence.
So Harvey Weinstein or
Hamlet, or Henry the 8th
but also thank God, the saucy herald,
the unhappy princesses, the unknown mutes,
the handsome cavalier.
The buried and mangled and bleeding
and disfigured and dashed to pieces,
already puny, unathletic body of Conrad.
My hunch is that camp is
a way to avoid contempt.
And this is for Spinoza, the
opposite feeling of wonder.
Contempt is the conception of anything
which touches the mind so little
that its presence leads the mind
to imagine those qualities
which are not in it
rather than such as are in it.
An example of contempt here.
Like last week I went to
a very straight, very
white millennial wedding.
And it's a soul destroying experience.
It's like, you think.
Is he really gonna kiss the bride?
Are they really gonna
feed each other cake?
Is there really gonna be a first dance?
And they do, they do all of it.
And it would be horrible
except that a few days before
I had gone at NYU to the
Halloween Drag Queen Cinderella
big extravagant performance.
And there's some way in which
drag redeems the rituals
of heterosexuality.
So in camp, you get to eat
the cake you're stuck with.
No matter that it's made of shit
and guaranteed to make you sick
and will probably kill you.
But here's a better
version of that metaphor.
You don't have to ingest
the cake yourself.
But you do get to cheer on all the queens
while they're eating it.
And not just eating it,
but ripping off each
other's tiaras over it.
Stuffing it in each other's
bra cups and jock straps.
Wrapping the goopy pieces of it
in glittered wax paper
and tinselated ribbon.
And then firing all of those packages
out of a unicorn rainbow
poo shooting cannon
so that it pours over the whole fiesta
like confetti at a Donna Summer concert.
That was the gay version of Gena's thing.
That's all, that's it.
(audience clapping)
- I find that very hard to follow.
(everyone laughing)
- That's substitute teacher.
(everyone laughs)
- Thanks Jonathan and
Nicole for today, such fun.
I too am gonna talk about
the sounds of "Otranto."
So as John beautifully showed us,
there's lots to say about the
novels and articulate sounds.
Which anticipate a now
familiar Gothic soundscape
of the disembodied indefinite eerie.
For example, a passage John cited.
"An awful silence reigned
"throughout those subterraneous regions.
"Except now and then some blasts of wind
"that shook the doors [Isabella] had passed
"and which, graying on the rusty hinges
"were re-echoed through that
long labyrinth of darkness.
"Every murmur struck
her with a new terror."
Isabella van Elferen's book,
"Gothic Music: The Sounds of
the Uncanny" cites this passage
as it summarized the Gothic conventions
that "Otranto" helped shape.
"The advent of terror
is generally preceded by
"an unworldly silence aided by
"meteorological wind, thunder, rain
"or technical rattling fences,
hissing pipes, circumstances
"and announced by sounds
that suggest presence.
"Creaks, echoes, voices, music."
Indeed, van Elferen treats
echo as the perfect figure
for what she calls the in/
materiality of Gothic sound.
An echo "suggests physical presence
"but it is disconnected from it
"like a phantom doppelganger
of its former self."
My new project is an intellectual history
of the sound of words and of
poetic sound in particular.
So I want to talk today in
a rather speculative way
about the novel's articulate sounds.
The way the sounds link with semantics.
If Walpole's re-echoing participates
in the Gothic tradition
of disembodied sounds
that tantalizingly suggest
but refuse to confirm some other presence.
His various ways of
highlighting articulate sounds
might suggest a different understanding.
As themselves present and embodied.
Fascinating work by actually
many people in this room
has underscored the importance
of the novel's things.
I'm asking if the novel's
sketches too the possibility
that words are a kind of thing.
So approached as many 18th
century writers approached them
echoes were a useful figure
for this understanding too.
I have to admit that I've
been thinking way too much
recently about Pope's "The sound must seem
"an echo to the sense" and
then echoes in particular.
Walpole did some thinking
about echoes too.
Post "Otranto," he wrote a silly
one act performance piece
featuring the early modern
tradition of Echo Verse.
In this tradition, words are
compounded material things
moving through space and time.
Words bounce around, disaggregate
and their parts change meaning.
So in a traditional echo
verse, a speaker asks,
"Tell me what is that supreme delight?"
and the echo answers, "Light."
So delight, light comes apart.
In Walpole's version, a
hilarious version actually.
A fairy punishes a man with a
loss of some part of himself.
But he gets to choose which part.
He must communicate his choice to echo.
The man chooses an
expendable part, his tears.
But the echo catches only ears.
"I did not say my ears," the man insists.
But the echo hears only
confirmation, ears.
Desperate, the man tries to
break the word into parts.
My T E A R S, but of course
the echo catches only E A R S.
Like other Echo Verse, Walpole's
jeu d'esprit treats sounds
as the building blocks of sense
in a resolutely material way
combining, recombining, drifting, moving.
Echoing sounds need not be thought of as
immaterial phantom
doppelgangers of lost presence.
They are themselves
present nuggets of meaning
moving through space and time.
Walpole's novel seems literally
to begin with something like
the Echo Verse disaggregation of E A R S.
For the title page gives the
real Italian writer's name
as Unophrio Muralto.
As Sir Walter Scott has suggested
this name is a sort of
anagram of Horatio Walpole.
Four letters are missing
and some new ones are added.
Scott also calls that
a kind of translation.
And after him, some fantastic
theories have been floated.
Wal goes French, Mur, apole can be alto,
Italian for high and so on.
Letters and sounds pull
apart, drift, recombine.
They signify and obscure.
"Otranto" features other sound play
in the spirit of Echo Verse as well.
When Matilda faints after overhearing
Manfred sentence Theodore to death.
Bianca shrieks, "Help,
help the princess is dead."
Bianca's words move.
Manfred hears them and
stops what he is doing
to figure out what happened.
We later find out that the
words traveled yet further.
And as they moved, their meaning shifted.
A monk visiting the
castle, heard the scream
and then brought word to the convent
that another princess, Hippolita was dead.
Sounds are wayward things.
They carry meaning but
not always reliably.
If here, the sounds retain
their proper shapes as words
unlike tears, ears.
Walpole also allowed sound shapes
to morph in their movements.
Thus his comic malapropism.
When the servant Jaquez, who
Manfred calls a blockhead
is reporting the supernatural
sight his friends saw
while they were supposed
to be looking for Isabella.
He says, "we were comprehensive
we might meet a ghost."
He means apprehensive.
And there's a playful
irony in the fact that
because they were apprehensive,
they were totally failing
to be comprehensive in their search.
The idea I think is that Jaquez
has heard apprehensive before.
He held onto the word and
now tries to work with it.
But he isn't in control of
the sound and the sense both.
There's an extra materially
charged irony here
in that there is an etymological
link between the two words.
The Latin prehendere , to grasp
which is exactly what
Jaquez fails at doing.
Words move, and their
physical parts and meanings
can shift in the traveling,
grasping and reusing.
Of course, like Echo Verse and anagram.
Both the overheard phase
and the clownish malapropism
have long literary histories.
But the fact that the
conventions are borrowed
don't undercut, doesn't undercut
the way of thinking sound that they offer.
If the sounds of words
are wayward materials
depending on prehendere, suggests that
they are also historical materials.
Walpole often uses obsolete
or archaic forms of English words.
The Broadview edition flags disculpate,
hallidane, wannat and corse for corpse.
As well as a whole host of terms
describing armor and architecture.
Such terms, like the historical objects
that some of them reference,
persist from the past.
And especially with the archaic spellings
it's particularly their
corporeal shape as words that persist.
There are other ways too
that the novel's words get aligned
with its historical things.
Theodore's body is marked
as Jill and Wendy just nicely reminded us.
His facial features have
an exact resemblance
to his ancestor Alphonso
and his back bears the
mark of the bloody arrow.
But his name too is the thing
that contains this big secret.
As scholars have noted, Theodore
comes from the Greek words
Theos and Dore, it means God given.
"My name is Theodore," he says climatically
just before his father recognizes him.
And in the end, Theodore is both good,
rightful heir to "Otranto."
Given "Otranto" by supernatural forces.
Of course the etymological secret
is made the more complicated
by the editor's proposal
that the names of the
novel are fictitious.
Probably disguised on purpose.
But whether we think the name
comes from Jerome and his wife
or from an artful Medieval
writer or from Walpole himself,
Theodore is the product
of a prior act of naming
that marks his prior right to "Otranto."
Certainly, we can't put this
pressure on all of the names.
But in all of his sound play,
including the eerie echos
that interest van Elferen in
her account of Gothic sound.
Walpole throws out possibilities
without fully developing them.
In some intriguing ways,
Hallidane wanted Theodore.
Walpole's words are like echoes.
Sounds that move meaningfully,
if unpredictably through space and time.
Since I've been working here alongside
but against the grain
of van Elferen's account
I'll close as she does.
She notes that for all its talk of sounds
the page of the Gothic
novel is itself mute.
Grace Poole's laughter in "Jane Eyre"
is all the more frightening
because it is doubly removed
from its alleged origin.
First through its ghostly disembodiment
and second, because the reader
does not actually hear it.
For van Elferen, the mute page
makes Gothic sounds doubly
immaterial and uncanny.
This is not I think, how Walpole's
various plays with the
sounds of words work.
If anything, repeated phrases,
malapropisms and etymologies
heighten our sense of the
physical qualities of words.
In our ears and on the page.
The sound plays thus seem related
to other found texts in the novel.
The couplet written on
the unearthed saber blade.
The ancient prophecy
difficult to make any sense of
which is said to have pronounced
that word interests me.
The downfall of the present family.
And of course Walpole first
presented his novel itself
as a found object.
Like the sounds that
features the novel itself
as a material historical wayward thing.
This brings me to a
final question or puzzle.
I've long been struck by the way
the sound of the novel changes at the end.
Throughout, Walpole
favors alliterative pairs
and pious intentions, reason
to rejoice, they're everywhere.
But then Manfred stabs Matilda
and suddenly we get these
intense patches of alliteration
that feel to me like a departure
from the earlier prose.
You'll just have to listen here.
"Murderous monster" cried Manfred.
"Heaven directed my bloody
hand to the heart of my child.
"The earth rocked and the clank of
"more than mortal armor was heard behind.
"Our doom is pronounced.
"Shall we not, can we not but dedicate
"the few deplorable hours we have to live
"in deprecating the
farther wrath of Heaven."
You should have these written
out, so I don't have to look.
I truly don't know what to make of these.
The alliteration amps up
right as the drama reaches its crisis.
So we might think of something
like what Garrett Stewart sees
as carefully knotted linguistic
and psychological threads in "Jane Eyre."
But murderous monster and Manfred
come from different voices.
And I'm not sure that there's
any necessary relation
between alliteration and emotion.
In fact, one might think
that in moments of intensity
the mediating material of
text might seem to fall away.
There is an onomatopoeia in
the clank of supernatural armor
but this isn't consistent either.
For how do breathy Hs fit stabbing?
Or the drum beat of Ds a pious resolution.
I haven't quite figured
out the logic of this
but I'm tempted to think about
these alliterative bursts
in relationship to the
Echo Verse disaggregation
of T E A R S, or the
anagrammatic play of Muralto.
Relevant too, is the argument
recurrent in "Prosody" after Milton
that there is something
distinctively Gothic about rhyme.
"The invention of a barbarous age."
Especially and so far as it involves
trivial play with jingling words.
Like the castle walls
crumbling behind Manfred.
Words are material and mortal.
Fallen, fallible, emotion-evoking
and anyway all we got.
When Walpole uses alliteration
to emphasize the letters of
his words at the novel's end.
Might he again be embracing the fact
that words are made of sounds
embody material phenomena that combine,
disaggregate, recombine,
persist echoing one another.
Thanks.
(audience clapping)
- Open it to questions.
- I have questions for the two papers on sound.
I love the analogy to film.
But I was wondering why you need film
when there is such a pronounced
and interesting tradition
of achieving stage effects
by unreal sounds?
So I know Garrick talks about how
the player who plays Macbeth
should wear cork in his shoes
so that he can walk
across the stage silently
for the murder scene.
It seems that many of the
things that you're describing
seem to be a consequence of the thing
that for me is paramount,
that this is a translation of
a five-act drama into a novel.
So would be interested to quickly add that
I love the concept of echoes
and I mean you should think about
I mean the notion of character
echos in the Gothic.
So when do we hear that the name
Theodore in "The Monk"
that is meant to echo that
character Theodore that we get
in "Castle of Otranto." (indistinct)
I see what it is in texts
like "The Monk," Ambrosio
seems echo to Antonio which tells us about
the connection as well.
- Go ahead.
- Yeah, that's great, that's super useful.
And I like the way then that
the character itself is being,
like the name is the kind of
material metonymy for that
and then it's picked up out of the text.
So there's something kind of
portable and trinkety
or something about that.
I'll have to do more
thinking, that's great.
- John.
Do you want to pick up the
other part of the question?
I believe in both and I wouldn't rule out
the things from the 18th-century theater.
But I do think there's a value added
in the sound theorist because the
notions like the psycho acoustic contract.
And the acousto-sonic contract
in which you get a
multiplication or a magnification
of the effect by the presentness of both.
Now that could happen
in the theater as well.
But I think also the methodical use of
real sounds in the Foley artist's lab
to make effects that
are either on the one hand
like those sounds in film
or the use of completely different objects
to make sounds that become real.
Probably we could find analogues in theater
but I think it's much
more vivid in film theory.
I don't see any harm, I guess
and I do see value added.
But the historical dimension
from the 18th-century theater
would be great as well.
And of course Walpole was involved in it
and Marshall Brown writes about the
effects of the Gothic in
plays prior to Walpole.
So I don't doubt that it's there.
- I just, to follow up
with a quick question
which is not "Otranto"
based, but just Foley based
which I didn't know
anything about until today.
Are those sound dubbers as it were,
are they watching the
film as they do this?
They're not following a script?
- No, they're watching the film.
- They're watching, okay so
it's visual as they're doing.
Cindy?
- Well this speaks to the value added
that you just mentioned John.
And I think this could
bring you in too, Courtney.
But what your Foley
effects made me think of.
You said the audio visual
contract applies to everything
kind of except dialogue.
But Joe's reading made me think
in "Otranto," practicing
the Gothic more generally.
The dialogue itself is laid on.
That's one of the things
that Lewis didn't like.
He said how could this
be realistic dialogue.
And then he quoted some of these lines.
(audience laughs)
Even then they didn't
talk like this, did they?
So there is a kind of sonic overlay
in the text itself, and the
Foley effect of the dialogue.
- Yeah I can see that, yes.
There is sometimes
dubbed dialogue in films.
But in general, the dialogue
will have been recorded on set
but there are many, many instances
where sound is dubbed in.
(Indistinct) Most obviously singers in musicals.
- Yeah?
- Alliteration sounds louder
than they're actually talking.
- Yes. Sandra.
- So I was hoping Sarah
that you and Sean might be able
to talk about the arabesque
because on Sean's account,
like ornamentality is a kind of
multiplication of, yeah
kind of multiplicity
or mode of multiplication.
Whereas for you, this idea of
the border exerting its own agency
seems different from that
account of the arabesque
"as its multiplicity. Right"
So that was my sense of their being,
a kind of different logic
to each of your accounts
of something that on its
face might be understood.
Even in mainstream aesthetics
in their own period as similar.
So I'm just throwing that out there.
- I mean, the arabesque isn't a term
I've thought a huge amount
before writing this paper.
So I think what was striking to me
in the characterizations
of it that I was reading
was that it was on the one hand
sort of picking up on the
idea of the serpentine,
was characteristic of the arabesque.
But that there were also these,
that the term shellwork is used.
And even although Kant doesn't talk
or use the term arabesque
but he talks about shellwork
and describes formations
that people think of,
could be described as arabesque.
But I definitely think I
don't want to make the claim
that it's just one dimensional
or linear and not complex.
The thing I was struck by more
was that if you hear me say.
Oh, mine is about thread
and then yours is about
weaving and complexity.
It sounds like I'm setting up a kind of
opposition that I don't really,
I don't want to do that.
And I'm getting the language
of the thread and the shell,
I'm getting from Hogarth where he
as you know, I'm sure many of you know
he talks about the threads as
the shell is made up of
a network of threads.
So it is a kind of complex
and he's not trying to make
it into a binary opposition
between two completely distinct forms.
So I think there's room for both of those.
The emphasis on bordering
and on complexity.
- But then the pelvic bones
are kind of exemplar of
ornamentation of the arabesque.
And there's something about pelvic bones, that are
with respect to the human body,
the very idea of reduction say in your vocabulary
So the carriage, the under, the irreducible.
And yeah, the irreducible
basis of the form.
- I wasn't ready for the pelvic bone.
(audience laughs)
- No one ever is Sean.
(audience laughing)
- Alright.
- Pelvic bone, is that from filming?
What is that from?
- The analysis that there's the.
You know, this shape.
- Right, right, right, right.
I do, I think I understand, I think.
- There's a clear way.
And this is probably tangential.
But there's a clear way in which Hogarth.
It's quite clear to me that
he's responding to a discourse
that emerges in the late 17th century
about the worldliness of things.
And that turns up in its own way
when he starts thinking seriously about
what it means to do engraving.
And he stumbles over the question of
the fact that engraving looks like,
looks unfortunately like texture.
But he also wants to get
to a sense of how is it
that individual lines add up to surface.
And that's the fun, that's one of the ways
that late 18th-century philosophy
comes to the notion of
emergent properties.
How you can take individual lines
and add them up to surface.
So I mean that's what I see as being the,
as a root from.
The root from thread to shell in Hogarth
as he's working it out.
- Yeah.
- There's a different
dimension that has to do with
specifically the serpentine
that has to do with returning
to embodied movement
because that's the line
that occupies space.
- I have a question.
But I wanted to state
something real quickly
with the shell thread conversation.
This is something that Sarah
and I have talked about before
but I'm struck in the context
of the Gothic and "Otranto"
by the fact that Hogarth in the moment
that he wants to turn
the shell into a metaphor
for this linear figure made of threads.
His phrasing is, he says like
imagine a shell with its
contents scooped out so nicely.
As I've talked to Sarah before
about how I find this phrase so gory.
(everyone laughs)
And evocative.
But then he actually has to go through
the motions of imagining
scooping out the material,
organic contents of an
actual biological shell.
Right, that has a creature inside.
In order to turn it into a
figure of just threads and lines.
And anyway, so there's something,
there's a kind of haunting,
there's this kind of gory haunting.
- And I know you have another question.
But it just makes me think
that they would have had to
scoop out the helmet presumably.
- Right?
- Because otherwise they would have been.
- Oh I see.
- Because it had Conrad stuck to it.
- All his remains were there, right?
- Right, yeah.
But I actually have a question
inspired by Courtney's
discussion of echo.
And I want to bring Courtney's
and Wendy's papers together.
I'm gonna try.
So I don't know if you've
already thought about this.
But when you were describing,
when you were doing your reading of echoes
and particularly the Echo Verse.
Where the echo is this reiteration
with a very minor, formal distortion
that has an enormous consequence
in terms of the meaning
or the significance
of the utterance.
It seemed to describe so perfectly
the epigraph to "The Castle of Otranto."
The little passage from Horace
that I think Sean made reference to
in his paper this morning.
But where he misquotes
Horace from the "Ars Poetica."
And it's a very, very minor tweak, right?
Like he alters the language
in this really minor way
but completely reverses the meaning.
So the "Ars Poetica" kind of says
in the grotesque or the ridiculous.
The head and the foot
cannot be reconciled to.
You know, there's strange fantasies
where the head and foot
cannot be reconciled to a single form.
And the epigraph to "Otranto" says
strange, strange fantasies in which
the head and the foot are nevertheless
reconciled to a single form.
So this reminded me of Wendy's claim
that I completely agree with.
That there's something about camp
that redeems heterosexual forms.
There's something about that echo
and the distortion it performs
that nevertheless gives a
form or restores to a form.
It's like camp distort is an
echo of this horrible original
that distorts it in such a way
that it actually provides
a redeemed form for it.
Like it gives it a redeemed
form to go forward.
- By redeem I meant like,
not want to kill yourself.
(everyone laughs)
- But that's kind of what I mean too.
But camp or parody or whatever it is
as a kind of echo in this sense.
I guess I'm just wondering.
If that's at all a different
way of thinking about it?
Or if echo is just a term
I've not thought about
that I'm kind of making describe
things like camp and parody
the way we've always,
or we've been describing
them for a long time.
- I mean that's great.
The only thing that comes to mind
is the thing with the partial
because you take off the T.
So whereas I think camp
is like the whole shebang.
Not the partial.
But you know.
- I have a sort of follow up question
that pertains to it.
which was you know, the alliterative stuff
that you were reading at the end there.
And your YouTube video.
I mean they're both very camp.
And it made me think about Pope's thing
about "the sound must seem
an echo to the sense."
Which I also have never understood
except at the most nominal level.
And it made me wonder whether
he's talking about the
affective and formal
life of camp actually.
Which sort of explains why it's
"the sound must seem an echo to the sense."
So I get what you're saying
that it's not partial.
It's beyond, it's like
more than not less than.
- Right.
- But yeah.
- I would say like in echo
verse that also happens.
Like other ones say like.
Oh "What do women most prize
when we men address?"
Like it ends with "a dress."
Like what do.
And then what women most
prize is a space dress.
- Right?
- Right.
- Or even just the ears
and then ears comes back.
So I think there is a way.
I don't know what you think about this.
But I guess that I would think that
one of the things Echo Verse does is just
throw attention onto like
the matter that's bringing it to us.
Right, or it brings attention
to the medium in a certain way
which you're reading did exactly as well.
Just kind of bring attention
to the wroughtness of the words right?
This is like half thought.
But I was thinking Sophie
actually of your paper
and the tension and the contrast between
belief and action, right.
Maybe there's a way in which
by just throwing
attention onto the bodily,
onto the medium, onto the corporeal side
it just sort of undercuts earnest belief
like true and spiritual.
It's not like they really think
in those sort of overwrought terms.
But there's a kind of awareness
that deflates a little bit.
- So John is this really
different than a Foley effect?
Because on the one hand, a Foley effect
more real than real but it's not.
And it's emphasizing the materiality
in the key turning or the foot stomping.
But to completely mask, I mean the effect
is pure reality in other words.
You're not?
- In our perception of it.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- It's not camp.
Foley effect is not camp.
- Well not if it's effective.
(audience laughs)
- I mean because then it seems to be
part of a kind of natural world of the film.
- But in that clip it is.
In the clip it is.
- Yes I was thinking of that too.
- There you got the film making
a meta comment on itself.
I had a question for you.
Could I quickly go back to Jesse's.
There was a medium other than
theater in the 18th century.
Which was phantasmagoria.
Which really comes into its own
in the later part of the century.
But there were sound
effects in that as well.
But Wendy, I wonder.
Maybe I missed something, but
Do you believe that
"Otranto" was camp in 1764?
Or is it only camp later?
Including now.
- I don't know.
It seems like it always had
to be camp but I don't know.
I mean I guess camp.
- A lot of people were
scared to death by it.
There's a story about
people going out on a boat
and reading it by candlelight.
- Oh I guess I was thinking
was it camp for Walpole?
What do you think the answer to that is?
I mean this is.
- Well there are parts of it I guess.
- Yeah.
- Not just this screwball stuff
in the dialogue
but even at the very beginning.
- Well if you go back to Pope.
- That's scary.
- If you go back to the Scriblerian
"Peri Hupsous," "The Art of Sinking in Poetry"
which we were talking about.
And I mean there's, if not camp
certainly a sendup element
of the faults sublime
already there in whenever that was written,
1720 or 18 or 21 or something like that.
But that group of people.
So that notion of a sendup of the serious
is certainly already there.
And their mock panegyrics
and other mock forms.
"Tale of the Tub" is brimming with them.
Is that the same as camp?
I'm just not sure, I think.
- Yeah no I don't think quite.
- I think Macaulay talking about
Walpole's taste in antiquaries
but maybe also "The Castle of
Otranto" uses the term, the odd
which I always thought was a
kind of good expression of.
Maybe that's not quite the camp
and it's not quite the novel
but it's something a little off.
- It's not snarky, you know.
I mean, you say more.
Camp is really, like it's only
doing the Donna Summer thing
because it's like weeping all the time.
It's like so sad, camp is really sad.
And it's just choosing
not to be sad about it.
I don't know.
- You said it's the, when
you said it's the wraparound.
It's tears without ears.
(everyone laughs)
- Or ears with it.
I mean if it's sad but.
Wait, what did you just say?
It's sad without being sad about the sad.
- I don't know, yeah.
- Then it would be more
like ears without tears.
- Ears without tears, yeah.
- Right.
- Put it in a question mark.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Quotation mark with a question mark.
Because I say the sky is blue
with an exclamation
point, it's surprising.
- If you jump off from Sontag then.
Her ideas, I recall it from years ago.
Is that there's fundamentally
always some other reference.
That there's a jump off in
the camp from something else.
And what's the something
else if it was camp in 1764?
- What's the something else?
I mean, patriarchy.
I mean it's the script in which,
the overreach of authority, that script.
Or the meta-novelistic script of
the peering into the recesses
of your heart script.
I mean, I don't know.
Were you thinking?
- I would follow him, he's
quite explicit on the topic.
- Oh say.
- It's the Fielding Richardson novel.
- Yeah.
- He's tired of it.
It doesn't have enough in it.
It doesn't have fantasy in it.
- Yeah.
- That's what's being setup, I think.
Whether you call it camp or not.
It's that kind of high
novel that we so adore.
- Yeah.
- Is what he's sending up.
He says it right at the preface.
- But you make this brilliant point John
that has been so influential to me.
That the Richardsonian novel's
always setting itself up.
Like it's always self-exposed,
committed to a kind of self exposure.
- Yeah, which is why a lot
of people don't like it.
- Yeah.
- I was just gonna say.
If on a very basic level of camp effect
of something of something
like a drag performance
has to do, or is contingent upon
the sort of indeterminacy between
essential and natural states
and perform the state.
There is a sort of tie
in to your paper Sarah
about the way in which every
time we think we have a frame.
- Yeah.
- "Castle of Otranto" be a frame of affect
or a frame of character.
And I think on a certain level
the text is sort of
performing indeterminacies
all across the board.
Which perhaps has a sort-of
affected defect
similar to sitting in a drag show
where there is a certain sort of
nervous tension that has to break.
You have to become
comfortable with the fact that
the figure before you is
in state of performance.
Could be that they are indeterminate.
- Yeah.
- Text also is flowing
back and forth quickly
and it doesn't really know what it is.
The reader doesn't know what it is.
- Yeah that seems right to me.
I was thinking when you were talking Wendy
that in some ways I
feel like I was saying.
Because when you were quoting Spinoza
on wonders, the concept of anything
when the mind comes to a stand.
It was like oh God I was just making
the same argument over again
because I was kind of saying the book
makes the mind come to a stand.
But I don't think I want to call it wonder
or that's not trying to say that.
But it's the effect of that
indeterminacy or code switching
where are you experiencing
this as a suspenseful novel
or are you immersed in it.
Or is somebody, are the
characters in the novel
following clues or are
they just experiencing
these weird dream states
and hallucinations
and not knowing what to do with them?
- Or even in a setup with
Walpole's second preface
are you experiencing
romance or a realist novel.
- Yeah.
- Push you back and forth.
- Exactly.
- Yeah I was thinking more about
how the prefaces have a.
I mean, I know I'm just
seeing shells everywhere now
but just the fact that
there are these frames.
That there are these frameworks
that almost overwhelm the text itself.
- Yeah.
- And as Margaret Doody has argued
perhaps with excessive vigor.
The romance was still very much in print
and alive at this time.
So that switching is not between
a hypothetical form
that's old and a new form.
They're both there.
- So this might not be surprising.
But I guess I want to actually push back
a little bit against this
language of indeterminacy
or maybe to get more precise about
what we're talking about
when we're pointing at certain
things that happen in the text.
So I spent a lot of time
in the last two weeks
when I was teaching this,
trying to figure out
what actually comes out of
the frame in that scene.
Because it isn't in fact the portrait,
if by the portrait you mean
the thing on the canvas.
I think it's actually supposed to be
the figure on the canvas.
- Yeah.
- Because that's the only
thing that can shake its head.
Okay, so I just want to say that.
So that we know what we're talking about.
And similarly with the cheek of the helmet
as your sort of emblem,
Sarah for this metaphor.
Because that's actually metonymy.
It's the cheek, the cheek is the helmet.
The helmet had the cheek
only to extent that
the helmet is designed to
point to the human body
that it no longer contains.
So those are two things,
two material
features of the text that
I want us to hold onto.
And then I wanted to point to something
that intrigued me about the Foley video.
Which is that there's an interesting,
a kind of interestingly naive literalism
where in order to produce the sound
they seem to feel they have to
move their bodies in the same way.
So the moment it really struck me
was when the guy falls down on the floor
in order to make the
sound of falling down.
Whereas presumably you
could make a sound like that
and we'd all sit in the
theater be like, yeah.
- There are countless examples
in literature about this.
This video just happened to be
the most vivid I could find.
But also I had to cut,
it's five minutes long
and I only had 10 minutes.
I had to cut it off
before the leg of lamb.
There's a big fight and they're
socking this leg of lamb.
(everyone laughs)
- So there we have a kind of,
so it's not so much it seemed to me
that we've got realism without the real.
We've got the real but detached from the.
- From the putative.
- From one reference right.
- We have two realities.
- So this is all very confused
but it seemed to me that what's happening
when we talked about
indeterminacy and frames
and we too easily slip into saying
what's moving out of the picture.
And the picture is moving out of the frame
is a kind of de-materialization.
Which we do all the time.
It's a metaphor for some larger things.
And then there you have a kind of
naive commitment to a materiality
which would require that
the sounds of the human body in motion
would have to be produced by that body
or version of that body in
the same kind of motion.
- It's a technical problem
in the making of film.
I mean in theory, all
those falls and so forth,
when they were shot,
could have been recorded
on the soundtrack with the dialogue.
But it doesn't work
because there's so much
other noise around.
And so with certain Foley things
there just has to be a literalness,
the click of the latch.
Now they can go to a lot more work
and click the latch some other way.
And in fact now, much of
that is digital anyway.
I mean, the real Foley is
this kind of physicality.
But I think to me.
- I guess if it's a simulacrum.
Why is it such a kind of
literal, naively literal simulacrum?
- You would, if you just had the video
of the two guys and all of their stuff.
Assuming you would accept the
idea of the chase in the film
creates a certain suspense.
You would not experience
that watching these guys
hammer on trash cans and fall over and go.
And did you notice how the one guy
running down the hall went (stomps feet)?
- Yeah.
- And so.
- To represent distance.
- Yes exactly, that's right.
So I think your point's
well taken in some ways
but the, I guess if
this were a longer paper
I would go more into parallel
technical issues in the novel
about how these effects become real.
I used this blanket term about
the audio visual contract
to kind of cover a lot of that.
But it's, yeah.
- So just thinking.
So you're asking the question.
Why is a problem with materiality
being solved with materiality?
Which is, yeah or something.
Is that?
- I mean I guess I just wanted to know.
Does it matter for us to get clear on
what emerges from the frame?
- Yeah.
- In our account of what is
significant about that trope
or that moment or that.
- And it's still mimetic
is partly what you're saying isn't it?
That both in the Foley and the cheeks
that these are not just
objects or artificial effects
but they're still kind of
bound to the body in some way.
Whether it's like representationally
in the figure of the portrait
or that the cheeks because
they're molded on the cheeks.
And I think that's really true.
And I just wanted to say I
think you're totally right that
I don't want it to flatten it out all into
well everything's indeterminate
and then at the end that
seems boring and not true.
But yeah, I think we need to cling
to the specificity of
these particular moments.
And I would need to think harder
about exactly how they work
and in the panel and
the cheek of the cask.
- Part of what's coming
out of the frame is Walpole
with the second preface
that is his authorship.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- His reveals.
- Yeah.
- And yeah it's, what was I gonna say?
Oh well.
- He also apparently is thinking of
a particular portrait at Strawberry Hill
because he mentions that too in a letter.
He says when that happens,
you should think of
I don't remember what the portrait is.
So that would be interesting to know.
Like what specific images.
- To me though.
What is being imitated here?
To me this book is like sci-fi.
It's using the techniques
that we're familiar with
from the realist novel.
But what's being imitated isn't there.
And this is part of the critique
of the so-called, the
Fielding Richardson novel.
That's not there either.
But he's calling attention
to the not-thereness
of the objects being represented.
It's I think, a brilliant
treatice on mimesis
which is part of what I'm trying to get at
with the Foley effects.
- Just to be dumb for a second.
I mean the Richardson Fielding
thing kind of is there
in the sense that if you
sort of strip away all the
kind of Medieval stuff, it's basically
just a family having a row about.
- And he makes a clue that
he's keeping the psychological
realism of a modern author.
But he's just entertaining
with a magical world.
- Yeah his term is expanded fantasy.
There's not enough
fantasy in those novels.
- Also I wanted to ask you Sophie
a question about this.
As you see it out here. (indistinct)
It seems like Walpole is about
going on and encompasses
- Yeah.
- And then in the ways
of the novel itself.
By saying something like.
The credulity of this
world of the Middle Ages.
He uses the whole supernatural apparatus.
And then in the second preface
he goes away from that.
It seems like maybe there's
a status of internally
the novel had some sort of
contractual relationship
with the reader of what
we're supposed to believe
to transform you.
- Over the course of the book?
- Yeah, over the course.
- The publications of the book.
- Exactly.
- Scott takes that up in his preface
and tries to treat this
as an historical novel
to make it work.
- The reason I'm hesitating is that
I am interested in something
that A, I haven fully thought through
but B, I think is a little subtle.
Which is for me, which is
the obvious move to make about the Gothic
and all this kind of stuff and fantasy
and that video and everything.
Is to say, there's just to
be really simple about it.
There's way too much
empirical stuff going on.
There's way too much real,
there's way too much material.
There's way too much stuff
that's supposed to be
like the thing it's imitating.
So we should jump the other way
and we should reinstate belief.
We should prioritize
belief over knowledge.
credulity over skepticism.
Blah blah blah.
And what seems uninteresting
to me about that solution
is that it isn't true and it doesn't work.
(audience laughs)
This is sort of where I fall
off the edge of the world.
I don't really have that
much more to say about that
because I haven't thought it through.
But I think that the
Gothic isn't proposing
a return to the credulous
and the superstitious
or the immaterial or the
non-real, the counter empirical
as a sort of curative
or antidote to the real.
I don't think, even though
it makes that gesture.
It feels to me.
I've never thought about camp before.
So I'm very, very beginner mind about it.
But it feels interesting
to me in sort of this,
the relation of belief to knowledge
or of credulity to skepticism.
Feels similar to me in the Gothic
as the relation of camp
to heterosexual matrimony.
It is a solution
that does all the things
that you said, somehow.
But yeah, I have to think more about it.
But the note I would like to sound is that
it isn't, I'm trying to think through the.
And this is where all the stuff about
involuntary obligation.
What was the other thing I talked about?
Like, okay I can't remember but anyway.
That's where that all comes in.
Because I'm sort of trying
to think through this idea.
Basically I'm just trying
to think through the idea
that we don't have to continue to chew on
the kind of remnants of
credulity versus skepticism
and belief versus knowledge
and all that stuff.
And yet we're dealing
with here's the archive.
- Yeah and over time you have to really
just willing suspension at this point.
- Right, right, right.
- Because what happens,
it's taken for granted.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And actually on that point.
I would say that Coleridge
is in fact putting his.
It's not like Coleridge thinks up
the willing suspension
of disbelief per se.
But he puts his finger,
or he identifies something
that seems to me, he gives it a name
but it doesn't seem to me
that that's the origin moment
for that particular
intellectual cognitive move.
That's all of it, yeah.
- And where does Walpole's word fancy
fit into this belief skepticism.
- That's a good question.
So how does he use the word fancy?
- He does, that's precisely his word.
- No, how?
Can you read the quote?
- Yeah I can.
"Invention has not been wanting
"but the great resources of
fancy have been damned up
"by a strict adherence to common life."
- That's a really good question.
I don't know, I bet I could
give you a good answer to that
but I definitely can't do it right now.
(everyone laughs)
- Well, I mean.
- Do you know?
- This is a moment of methodism.
It's a continuing battle
against Catholicism.
- Yeah.
- In the Anglican Church.
- I think there are a lot of
phantasms of fancy out there.
- Yeah.
Well I mean, I guess part of what
I was trying to say about his dad
is that he was all, he was
sort of pretty invested in
making fancy more safe or something
by sort of limiting its impact.
- Is your Hoadly the guy Hogarth painted?
- Yes, yeah, yeah.
- Shall we continue the
conversation informally.
And thank all the panelists
today and this morning
for a wonderful, wonderful.
(audience clapping)